OK, when the camera
says, we'll start.
You want to give me a signal?
OK, this is lecture
eight in linear algebra,
and this is the lecture
where we completely
solve linear equations.
So Ax=b.
That's our goal.
If it has a solution.
It certainly can happen
that there is no solution.
We have to identify that
possibility by elimination.
And then if there is a solution
we want to find out is there
only one solution or are
-- is there a whole family
of solutions, and
then find them all.
OK.
Can I use as an
example the same matrix
that I had last
time when we were
looking for the null space.
So the, the matrix has
rows 1 2 2 2, 2 4 6 8,
and the third row -- you
remember the main point was
the third row, 3 6 8 10, is the
sum of row one plus row two.
In other words, if I add
those left-hand sides,
I get the third left-hand side.
So you can tell
me right away what
elimination is going to discover
about the right-hand sides.
What's -- there is a
condition on b1, b2,
and b3 for this system
to have a solution.
Most cases -- if I took
these numbers to be one --
5, and 17, there would
not be a solution.
In fact, if I took those
first numbers to be 1 and 5,
what is the only b3
that would be OK?
Six.
If the left-hand -- if these
left-hand sides add up to that,
then B --
I need b1 plus b2 to equal b3.
Let's just see how
elimination discovers that.
But we can see it coming, right?
That if -- let me say
it in other words.
If some combination
on the left-hand side
gives all 0s then
the same combination
on the right-hand
side must give 0.
OK.
So let me take that
example and write down
instead of copying out
all the plus signs,
let me write down the matrix.
1 2 2 2, 2 4 6 8,
and that 6 3 8 10,
where the third row is the
sum of the first two rows.
Now how do we deal with
the right-hand side?
That's -- we want to do the same
thing to the right-hand side
that we're doing to these
rows on the left side,
so we just tack on the
right-hand side as another
vector, another column.
So this is the augmented matrix.
It's, it's the matrix A
with the vector b tacked on.
In Matlab, that's all
you would need to type.
OK.
So we do elimination on that.
Can we just do
elimination quickly?
The first pivot is fine,
I subtract two of this
away from this, three
of this away from this,
so I have 1 2 2 2 b1.
Two of those away will
give me 0 0 2 and 4,
and that was b2 minus two b1.
I, I have to do the same
thing to that third,
that last column.
And then three of
these away from this
gave me 0 0 2 4 b3
minus three b1s.
So that's the,
that's elimination
with the first column completed.
We move on.
There's the first pivot still.
Here is the second pivot.
We're always remembering,
now, these are then
going to be the pivot columns.
And let me get the final
result -- well, let me --
can I do it by eraser?
We're capable of subtracting
this row from this row,
just by -- that'll knock this
out completely and give me
the row of 0s, and on
the right-hand side,
when I subtract this away
from this, what do I have?
I think I have b3 minus a b2,
and I had minus three b1s.
This is going to, it's
going to be a minus a b1.
Oh yeah that's
exactly what I expect.
So now the -- what's
the last equation?
The last equation, this
represented by this zero row,
that last equation is, says 0
equals b3 minus b2 minus b1.
So that's the condition
for solvability.
That's the condition
on the right-hand side
that we expected.
It says that b1+b2
has to match b3,
and if our numbers happen
to have been 1, 5, and 6 --
so let me take,
suppose b is 1 5 6.
That's an OK b.
And when I do this
elimination, what will I have?
The b1 will still be a 1.
b2 would be 5 minus
2, this would be a 3.
5 -- my 6 minus 5 minus
1, this will be --
this is the main point --
this will be a 0, thanks.
OK.
So the last equation is OK now.
And I can proceed to solve the
two equations that are really
there with four unknowns.
OK, I, I, I want to do
that, so this, this b is OK.
It allows a solution.
We're going to be,
naturally, interested
to keep track what are
the conditions on b that
make the equation solvable.
So let me write down
what we already see
before I continue to solve it.
Let me first --
solvability, solvability.
So which -- so this is the
condition on the right-hand
sides.
And what is that condition?
This is solvability
always of Ax=b.
So Ax=b is solvable --
well, actually, we had an answer
in the language of the column
space.
Can you remind me
what that answer is?
That, that was like our
answer from earlier lecture.
b had to be in the column space.
Solvable if -- when -- exactly
when b is in the column space
of A.
Right?
That just says that b has to be
a combination of the columns,
and of course that's exactly
what the equation is looking
for.
So that -- now I
want to answer it --
the same answer but
in different language.
Another way to answer this --
if a combination of the rows
of A gives the zero row,
and this was an example
where it happened,
some combination of the rows
of A produced the zero row --
then what's the
requirement on b?
Since we're going to do the
same thing to both sides of all
equations --
the same combination of the
components of b has to give 0.
Right?
That's -- so if there's a
combination of the rows that
gives the zero row, then the
same combination of the entries
of b must give 0.
And this isn't the zero
row, that's the zero number.
Tthis is another way of saying
-- and it is not immediate,
OK. right, that these two
statements are equivalent.
But somehow they must
be, because they're
both equivalent to the
solvability of the system.
OK.
So we've got this, this sort
of -- like question zero is,
does the system have a solution?
OK, I'll come back to
discuss that further.
Let's go forward when it does.
When there is a solution.
And so what's our job now?
Abstractly we sit back
and we say, OK, there's
a solution, finished.
It exists.
But we want to construct it.
So what's the
algorithm, the sequence
of steps to find the solution?
That's what I --
and of course the
quiz and the final,
I'm going to give you a system
Ax=b and I'm going to ask you
for the solution,
if there is one.
And so this algorithm
that you want to follow.
OK, let's see.
So what's the -- so now to find
the complete solution to Ax=b.
OK.
Let me start by
finding one solution,
one particular solution.
I'm expecting that I can,
because my system of equations
now, that last equation
is zero equals zero,
so that's all fine.
I really have two equations --
actually I've got
four unknowns, so I'm
expecting to find
not only a solution
but a whole bunch of them.
But let's just find one.
So step one, a particular
solution, x particular.
How do I find one
particular solution?
Well, let me tell you
how I, how I find it.
So this is --
since there are
lots of solutions,
you could have your own way
to find a particular one.
But this is a
pretty natural way.
Set all free variables to zero.
Since those free variables are
the guys that can be anything,
the most convenient
choice is zero.
And then solve Ax=b for
the pivot variables.
So what does that
mean in this example?
Which are the free variables?
Which, which are the variables
that we can assign freely
and then there's
one and only one way
to find the pivot variables?
They're x2 and -- so x2 is
zero, because that's in a column
without a pivot, the
second column has no pivot.
And the -- what's the other one?
The fourth, x4 is zero.
Because that, those
are the, the free ones.
Those are in the
columns with no pivots.
So you see what my
-- so when I knock --
when x2 and x4 are zero,
I'm left with the --
what I left with here?
I'm just left with --
see, now I'm not
using the two free
columns.
I'm only using
the pivot columns.
So I'm really left with x1 --
the first equation
is just x1 and two
x3s should be the
right-hand side, which
we picked to be a one.
And the second
equation is two x3s,
as it happened, turned
out to be, three.
I just write it again here
with the x2 and the x4
knocked out, since
we're set them to zero.
And you see that we're back in
the normal case of having back
-- where back
substitution will do it.
So x3 is three halves,
and then we go back up
and x1 is one minus two x3.
That's probably minus two.
Good.
So now we have the
solution, x particular
is the vector minus two
zero three halves zero.
OK, good.
That's one particular solution,
and we should and could plug it
into the original system.
Really if -- on
the quiz, please,
it's a good thing to do.
So we did all this,
these, row operations,
but this is supposed to
solve the original system,
and I think it does.
OK.
So that's x particular
which we've got.
So that's like what's new today.
The particular solution comes
-- first you check that you have
zero equals zero, so
you're OK on the last
equations.
And then you set the
free variables to zero,
solve for the pivot
variables, and you've
got a particular solution,
the particular solution that
has zero free variables.
OK.
Now -- but that's
only one solution,
and now I'm looking for all.
So how do I find the rest?
The point is I can add on x --
anything out of the null space.
We know how to find the
vectors in the null space --
because we did it last time,
but I'll remind you what we
got.
And then I'll add.
So the final result will be
that the complete solution --
this is now the complete guy --
the complete solution is
this one particular solution
plus any, any vector,
all different vectors out
of the null space.
xn, OK.
Well why, why this pattern,
because this pattern shows up
through all of mathematics,
because it shows up everywhere
we have linear equations.
Let me just put here
the, the reason.
A xp, so that's x particular,
so what does Ax particular give?
That gives the correct
right-hand side b.
And what does A times an
x in the null space give?
Zero.
So I add, and I
put in parentheses.
So xp plus xn is b
plus zero, which is b.
So -- oh, what I saying?
Let me just say it in words.
If I have one solution,
I can add on anything
in the null space, because
anything in the null space
has a zero right-hand
side, and I still
have the correct
right-hand side B.
So that's my system.
That's my complete solution.
Now let me write out what
that will be for this example.
So in this example, x
general, x complete,
the complete solution,
is x particular,
which is minus two
zero three halves zero,
with those zeroes in the
free variable, plus --
you remember there were the
special solutions in the null
space that had a one in
the free variables --
or one and zero in
the free variables,
and then we filled in to find
I've forgotten what they were,
but maybe it was
that. the others?
That was a special
solution, and then
there was another
special solution that
had that free variable zero and
this free variable equal one,
and I have to fill those in.
Let's see, can I remember
how those fill in?
Maybe this was a minus
two and this was a two,
possibly?
I think probably that's right.
I'm not -- yeah.
Does that look write to you?
I would have to remember
what are my equations.
Can I, rather than go
way back to that board,
let me remember the
first equation was
two x3 plus two x4
equaling zero now,
because I'm looking for
the guys in the null space.
So I set x4 to be one
and the second equation,
that I didn't copy again, gave
me minus two for this and then
-- yeah, so I
think that's right.
Two minus four and
two gives zero, check.
OK.
Those were the
special solutions.
What do we do to get
the complete solution?
How do I get the
complete solution now?
I multiply this by
anything, c1, say,
and I multiply
this by anything --
I take any combination.
Remember that's how we
described the null space?
The null space consists
of all combinations of --
so this is xn --
all combinations of
the special solutions.
There were two special
solutions because there
were two free variables.
And we want to
make that count --
carefully now.
Just while I'm up here.
So there's, that's what the
-- that's the kind of answer
I'm looking for.
Is there a constant
multiplying this guy?
Is there a free constant
that multiplies x particular?
No way.
Right? x particular
solves A xp=b.
I'm not allowed to
multiply that by three.
But Axn, I'm allowed to
multiply xn by three,
or add to another xn, because I
keep getting zero on the right.
OK.
So, so again, xp is
one particular guy.
xn is a whole subspace.
Right?
It's one guy plus, plus
anything from a subspace.
Let me draw it.
Let me try to -- oh.
I want to draw, I want
to graph all this --
I want to, I want to
plot all solutions.
Now x.
So what dimension I in?
This is a unfortunate point.
How many components does x have?
Four.
There are four unknowns.
So I have to draw a four
dimensional picture on this MIT
cheap blackboard.
OK.
So here we go.
x1 -- Einstein could do
it, but, this, this is --
those are four
perpendicular axes in --
representing four
dimensional space.
OK.
Where are my solutions?
Do my solutions form a subspace?
Does the set of solutions
to Ax=b form a subspace?
No way.
What does it actually
look like, though?
A subspace is in this picture.
This part is a subspace, right?
That part is some,
like, two dimensional,
because I've got two
parameters, so it's --
I'm thinking of this null space
as a two dimensional subspace
inside R^4.
Now I have to tell you and
will tell you next time,
what does it mean to say a
subspace, what's the dimension
of a subspace.
But you see what
it's going to be.
It's the number of free
independent constants
that we can choose.
So somehow there'll be a two
dimensional subspace, not
a line, and not a three
dimensional plane, but only
a two dimensional guy.
But it's doesn't go
through the origin
because it goes
through this point.
So there's x particular.
x particular is somewhere here.
x particular.
So it's somehow a subspace --
can I try to draw it that way?
It's a two dimensional subspace
that goes through x particular
and then onwards by --
so there's x particular,
and I added on
xn, and there's x.
There's x=xp+xn.
But the xn was anywhere
in this subspace,
so that filled out a plane.
It's a subspace --
it's not a subspace,
what I saying?
It's like a flat thing,
it's like a subspace,
but it's been shifted,
away from the origin.
It doesn't contain zero.
Thanks.
OK.
That's the picture, and
that's the algorithm.
So the algorithm is just
go through elimination
and, find the
particular solution,
and then find those
special solutions.
You can do that.
Let me take our time here
in the lecture to think,
about the bigger picture.
So let me think about --
so this is my pattern.
Now I want to think --
I want to ask you
about a question --
some questions.
So when I mean think bigger,
I mean I'll think about an m
by n matrix A of rank r.
OK.
What's our definition of rank?
Our current definition of
rank is number of pivots.
OK.
First of all, how are
these numbers related?
Can you tell me a
relation between r and m?
If I have m rows in the
matrix and R pivots, --
then I certainly know, always --
what relation do I
know between r and m?
r is less or equal, right?
Because I've got m rows, I
can't have more than m pivots,
I might have m and
I might have fewer.
Also, I've got n columns.
So what's the relation
between r and n?
It's the same, less or
equal, because a column
can't have more than one pivot.
So I can't have more
than n pivots altogether.
OK, OK.
So I have an m by
n matrix of rank r.
And I always know r less than
or equal to m, r less than
or equal to n.
Now I'm specially
interested in the case
of full rank, when the rank
r is as big as it can be.
Well, I guess I've got two
separate possibilities here,
depending on what these
numbers m and n are.
So let me talk about the
case of full column rank.
And by that I mean r=n.
And I want to ask you, what does
that imply about our solutions?
What does that tell us
about the null space?
about, the complete solution?
OK, so what does that mean?
So I want to ask you,
well, OK, if the rank is
n, what does that mean?
That means there's a
pivot in every column.
So how many pivot
variables are there?
n.
All the columns have
pivots in this case.
So how many free
variables are there?
None at all.
So no free variables.
r=n, no free variables.
So what does that
tell us about what's
going to happen then in our,
in our little algorithms?
What will be in the null space?
The null space of A
has got what in it?
Only the zero vector.
There are no free variables
to give other values to.
So the null space is
only the zero vector.
And what about our
solution to Ax=b?
Solution to Ax=b?
What, what's the
story on that one?
So now that's coming
from today's lecture.
The solution x is --
what's the complete solution?
It's just x particular, right?
If, if, if there is an x,
if there is a solution.
It's x equal x particular.
There's nothing -- you know,
there's just one solution.
If there's one at all.
So it's unique solution --
unique means only one --
unique solution if it
exists, if it exists.
In other words, I would say --
let me put it a different way.
There're either zero
or one solutions.
This is all in this case r=n.
So I'm -- because many, many
applications in reality,
the columns will be what
I'll later call independent.
And we'll have, nothing to
look for in the null space,
and we'll only have
particular solutions.
OK.
Everybody see that possibility?
But I need an example, right?
So let me create an example.
What sort of a matrix -- what's
the shape of a matrix that has
full column rank?
So can I squeeze in
an, an example here?
If it exists.
Let me put in an example,
and it's just the right space
to put in an example.
Because the example will
be like tall and thin.
It will have --
well, I mean, here's an example,
one two six five, three one
one one.
Brilliant example.
OK.
So there's a matrix A,
and what's its rank?
What's the rank of that matrix?
How many pivots will I
find if I do elimination?
Two, right?
Two.
I see a pivot there --
oh certainly those two
columns are headed off
in different directions.
When I do elimination, I'll
certainly get another pivot
here, fine, and I can use those
to clean out below and above.
So the -- actually, tell me
what its row reduced row echelon
form would be.
Can you carry that,
that elimination
process to the bitter end?
So what do, what does that mean?
I subtract a multiple of
this row from these rows.
So I clean up, all zeros there.
Then I've got some pivot here.
What do I do with that?
I go subtract it
below and above,
and then I divide through,
and what's R for that example?
Maybe I can -- you'll allow
me to put that just here
in the next board.
What's the row reduced echelon
form, just out of practice,
for that matrix?
It's got ones in the pivots.
It's got the identity matrix,
a little two by two identity
matrix, and below it all zeros.
That's a matrix that really
has two independent rows,
and they're the
first two, actually.
The first two rows
are independent.
They're not in the
same direction.
But the other rows are
combinations of the first two,
so --
is there always a
solution to Ax=b?
Tell me what's the picture here?
For this matrix A, this is
a case of full column rank.
The two columns are
-- give two pivots.
There's nothing
in the null space.
There's no combination
of those columns
that gives the zero column
except the zero zero
combination.
So there's nothing
in the null space.
But is there always a
solution to A X equal B?
What's up with A X equal B?
I've got four, four equations
here, and only two Xs.
So the answer is certainly no.
There's not always a solution.
I may have zero solutions,
and if I make a random choice,
I'll have zero solutions.
Or if I make a great particular
choice of the right-hand side,
which just happens to be a
combination of those two guys
-- like tell me one right-hand
side that would have
a solution.
Tell me a right-hand side
that would have a solution.
Well, 0 0 0 0, OK.
No prize for that one.
Tell me another one.
Another right-hand side that
has a solution would be 4 3 7 6.
I could add the two columns.
What would be the total
complete solution if the
Right? right-hand
side was 4 3 7 6?
There would be the
particular solution one
one, one of that column
plus one of that,
and that would be the only
solution.
So there would be -- x
particular would be one one
in the case when the right
side is the sum of those two
columns, and that's it.
So that would be a
case with one solution.
OK.
That, this is the typical
setup with full column rank.
Now I go to full row rank.
You see the sort of natural
symmetry of this discussion.
Full row rank means r=m.
So this is what I'm
interested in now, r=m.
OK, what's up with that?
How many pivots?
m.
So what happens when we do
elimination in that case?
I'm going to get m pivots.
So every row has a pivot, right?
Every row has a pivot.
Then what about solvability?
What about this business of --
for which right-hand sides can
I solve it?
So that's my question.
I can solve Ax=b for
which right-hand sides?
Do you see what's coming?
I do elimination, I
don't get any zero rows.
So there aren't any
requirements on b.
I can solve Ax=b for every b.
I can solve Ax=b for
every right-hand side.
So this is the existence,
exists a solution.
Now tell me, so the, u- u- so
every row has a pivot in it.
So how many free
variables are there?
How many free
variables in this case?
If I had n variables
to start with,
how many are used up
by pivot variables?
r, which is m.
So I'm left with, left
with n-r free variables.
OK.
So this case of full row
rank I can always solve,
and then this tells me how
many variables are free,
and this is of course n-m.
This is n-m free variables.
Can I do an example?
You know, the best way for
me to do an example is just
to transpose that example.
So let me take, let me take
that matrix that had column one
two six five and make it a row.
And let me take three one
one one as the second row.
And let me ask you, this is
my matrix A, what's its rank?
What's the rank of that matrix?
Sorry to ask, but
not sorry really,
because we're just
getting the idea of rank.
What's the rank of that matrix?
Two, exactly, two.
There will be two pivots.
What will the row
reduced echelon form be?
Anybody know that one?
Actually, tell me not only --
you have to tell me not only
the, there'll be two pivots
but which will be the pivot
columns.
Which columns of this matrix
will be pivot columns?
So the first column
is fine, and then
I go on to the next
column, and what do I get?
Do I get a second
pivot out of --
will I get a second
pivot in this position?
Yes.
So the pivots, when I get all
the way to R, will be there.
And here will be some numbers.
This is the part that
I previously called F.
This is the part that -- the
pivot columns in R will be
the identity matrix.
There are no zero rows, no zero
rows, because the rank is two.
But there'll be stuff over here.
And that will, enter the special
solutions and the null space.
OK.
So this is a typical matrix
with r=m smaller than n.
Now finally I've got a
space here for r=m=n.
I'm off in the corner here with
the most important case of all.
So what's up with this matrix?
So let me give an example.
OK, brilliant example, 1 2 3 1.
Tell me what -- how do I
describe a matrix that has rank
r=m=n?
So the matrix is square,
right, it's a square matrix.
And if I know its rank is
-- it's full rank, now.
I don't have to say full
column rank or full row rank --
I just say full rank, because
the count, column count
and the row count are
the same, and the rank
is as big as it can be.
And what kind of a
matrix have I got?
It's invertible.
So that's exactly the
invertible matrices.
r=m=n means the -- what's
the row echelon form,
the reduced row echelon form,
for an invertible matrix?
For a square, nice,
square, invertible matrix?
It's I.
Right.
So you see that the,
the good matrices
are the ones that kind of
come out trivially in R.
You reduce them all the
way to the identity matrix.
What's the null space for
this, for this matrix?
Can I just hammer
away with questions?
What's the null space
for this matrix?
The null space of that matrix
is the zero vector only.
The zero vector only.
What are the conditions
to solve Ax=b?
Which right-hand sides b are OK?
If I want to solve Ax=b for
this example, so A is this,
b is b1 b2, what are the
conditions on b1 and b2?
None at all, right.
So this is the case, this is
the case where I can solve --
so I've coming back here, I
can -- since the rank equals m,
I can solve for every b.
And since the rank is also
n, there's a unique solution.
Let me summarize the
whole picture here.
Here's the whole picture.
I could have r=m=n.
This is the case where this
is the identity matrix.
And this is the case where
there is one solution.
That's the square
invertible chapter two case.
Now we're into chapter three.
We could have r=m
smaller than n.
Now that's what
we had over there,
and the row echelon form
looked like the identity
with some zero rows.
And that was the case where
there are zero or one solution.
When I say solution
I mean to Ax=b.
So this case,
there's always one.
This case there's zero or one.
And now let me take the
case of full column rank,
but some, extra rows.
So now R has --
well, the identity --
I'm almost tempted to write
the identity matrix and then F,
but that isn't
necessarily right.
I have -- is that right?
Am I getting this correct here?
Oh, I'm not!
My God!
This is the case R equals n,
the columns, the columns are,
are OK.
That's the case that was on that
board, r=n, full column rank.
Now I want the case
where m is smaller than n
and I've got extra columns.
OK.
There we go.
So this is now the
case of full row rank,
and it looks like
I F except that I
can't be sure that the pivot
columns are the first columns.
So the I and the F, could
be partly mixed into the I.
Can I write that
with just like that?
So the F could be sort
of partly into the I
if the first columns
weren't the pivot columns.
Now how many solutions
in this case?
There's always a solution.
This is the existence case.
We're not getting any zero rows.
There are no zero rows here.
So there's always either one
or infinitely many solutions.
OK.
Actually, I guess there's
always an infinite number,
because we always have some
null space to deal with.
Then the final case is
where r is smaller than m
and smaller than n.
OK.
Now that's the case
where R is the identity
with some free stuff but
with some zero rows too.
And that's the case where
there's either no solution --
because we didn't get a zero
equals zero for some bs,
or infinitely many solutions.
OK.
Do you -- this board really
summarizes the lecture,
and this sentence
summarizes the lecture.
The rank tells you everything
about the number of solutions.
That number, the
rank r, tells you
all the information except the
exact entries in the solutions.
For that you go to the matrix.
OK, good.
Have a great weekend, and
I'll see you on Monday.